nice okay well thanks everybody for
welcome to my name is Jo Manning welcome
to the
now initiative lecture series it's
amazing it's year three already
it's an exciting year being launched
today by Professor Alpha T Delta here
from MIT and grateful for his for his
coming down he did his bachelors work at
the University of Khartoum did his PhD
at MIT and never left the joint as far
as I can tell he went he's went gone
from postdoc through the ranks to the
green M here professor of hydrology and
climate now he is a fellow of the
American Geophysical Union his CV is
incredible I have to say having having
read it through quite recently his range
of interest is also staggering I know
his work and the project knows his work
from work on Paleo climate and the Nile
River things like the cyan Delta here
explaining and forecasting inter-annual
variability in the flow of the now River
in hydrology and Earth's system Sciences
in 2015 and the hugely important role of
ENSO in particular that we're gonna hear
more about and so today and so as a main
driver of Nile River variability know
now mainly through his work climate
change enhances inter-annual variability
of the Nile River flow in Nature climate
change from a year or two ago
these are seminal articles in our
research project of course we've talked
a lot about them and joint with G Ling
Wong my lammeter's El Nino and climatic
variability that's the first article
that's way back from 1999 where I got to
know mu work in the geophysical research
letters now working on of course the
Nile River but also on things like
malaria and climate change worldwide
which is really rather
rather important work of course so
climate change unlikely to increase
malaria burden in West Africa for
example also nature climate change a
recent work which sort of showcases
among other things the work on that
front today really thrilled I can't wait
to hear you on hydrology and climate of
the now basin past present in future we
could not have a better way to launch
this year's lecture series thank you so
much for coming professor to here at the
floor is yours and thank you everyone
for inviting me here and for coming at
four o clock on Friday to listen to me
I appreciate that and I hope that you
will enjoy this this talk the picture I
show here is a picture for the north
eastern corner of Africa and you see
here even from space you see the Nile
River flowing until it's discharging
into the Mediterranean ocean you see
here this is the Red Sea
he's the European Highlands where most
of the water comes I my connection to
the Nile comes not only from my interest
and research and publications I was born
like a kilometer away from the river and
I lived most of my life like 100 meters
away from it and so by now I lived half
of my life back in Sudan and half of my
life in the US and I have been looking
at this system through research and so I
have somewhat unique perspective that I
would like to share with you today the
denial you know let me start by and and
so what I would like to talk about today
is to give you like snapshots on work
that we did looking at the past the
history of the of the Nile hydrology but
also things that are happening now and
some projections into the future my
background and expertise isn't really in
hydrology and climate Joe mentioned that
I did my undergraduate work in Sudan
a civil engineer and then I came and did
my PhD at MIT but there is an
intermediate step where I went through I
actually did a master in hydrology in
Ireland in Galway and so I tell people I
moved from a corner of the world lid
where the function of rivers is you take
water and you really gave the land to a
place where rivers drain the soil so
that you could grow crops so that's was
my background in hydrology and then when
I came to MIT I was fascinated by what's
going on in the atmosphere I wasn't
content on the focus that I had in
Galway where we only looked at rivers
and soil moisture and groundwater I
wanted to have a fuller picture of the
hydrologic cycle and so I spent a lot of
time at EBEs which is the Earth's
atmospheric and Planetary Sciences
department at MIT understanding climate
processes and and and taking classes
there so that's that the topic is going
to be the hydrology and climate of
denial so I would like to start looking
at the path by these pictures taken from
caves around the Sahara Desert and the
fascinating thing about these pictures
which are dated for thousands of years
back they show pictures of large animals
like elephants
cows giraffe in areas that now you don't
have that kind of animals existing there
the climate has changed and so those who
are taken as science of the Paleo
climate of that area and there is many
other records that have been summarized
in this paper things from like samples
from soil charcoal human bones large
animals fish plant remains scattered
around the desert pointing to the
history of the climate of that area
being different than the existing
climate now and as had been summarized
further in this organizer summarized in
this paper in science where you have in
this dimension you have basically
the south to north here in latitude
sixteen point five to twenty nine point
five degrees north this is basically
from the area north of current Khartoum
the capital of Sudan to the area just
south of Cairo so extending through
northern Sudan and southern Egypt and
you have time before present in this
dimension and what's shown here is
really the evidence that I showed
earlier being sorted out and organized
pointing to a green more humid period
that existed about maybe you know 5,000
to 9,000 years ago it's pointing to the
fact that the Sahara Desert was much
more humid during the during the
Holocene and myth holism period and
that's shown mere further here and this
series of maps from the same paper were
at 500 BCE you see evidence that
settlements were mostly along along the
river and then in following that eighty
five hundred to seven thousand and seven
thousand to seven fifty three hundred
there is a scattered settlements around
and then again after the drying came
about people basically moved to live
along the Nile Basin so there is a lot
of Paleo climatic evidence suggesting
how the dynamics of the Sahara Desert
and how how that changed through times
in timescales of thousands of years of
course this drying trend which is
similar to what the climate now you know
result was coincident or coincided with
emergence of the pharaonic civilization
and that's you know I'll show you here a
picture this is one of my favorite
pictures this is a picture of a Newton
and his wife Nefertiti Aten the God of
Sun and this is like maybe to dunk a
moon if I don't know if we know that but
that's possibly one of his sons I'm
going to come back to that picture I'm
showing this year not because I'm an
Egypt
so gist or an expert on archeology of
Fiji but but this is my favorite I call
this my favorites Faro this is the natin
he was quite a revolutionary guy parts
of the 18th dynasty
you know monotheism is like his maybe
the first guy who introduced to that
part of the world monotheism bringing
this god Adam
nothing is effective to uh turn
everything the names
Amenhotep his name before he made the
change was related to M&D the Godman and
then and then Nitin attend his part of
of his name he he was quite
revolutionary he moved the capital to
place called tell el-amarna in Egypt now
and some of you know about not more than
me
for me I'm showing it that it's just
like an example for for for for a
significant Pharaoh his mother however
ty who was quite a significant lady she
there are theories that she's of Nubian
origin of the awesome Egyptian you know
they may question some of that but she
was quite an influential woman and and
she lived only like for three years or
so during the period in which Jonathan
was was was basically the Pharaoh of
Egypt so so there is this shift in the
climate of the Sahara so one of the
internal issues that I'm interested in
the intellectual questions I ask is what
caused this shift in the other border
what processes triggered that shift in
the desert border and the expansion of
the Sahara and we would like to
understand that for fundamental reasons
but also we would like to test our
current group of models the
state-of-the-art models that describe
the climate system one of the test
example that we use for is trying to
understand how this desert border
happened is quite accepted that changes
in the orbital parameters of how the
airs
basically
rotates around the Sun played a
significant role changes in the
eccentricity cycle which has you know
100,000 years the obliquity cycle you
know the eccentricity is how eccentric
at this you know geometrical object and
how the obliquity which is the tilt of
the axis of the earth and how that
changes in time is caused of 41,000
years the precision which is the time in
which the the Earth's is closest to the
Sun and what time of the earth that
happens all these parameters do change
and so what's called the Milankovitch
theory it had been calculated what the
periods and what the variations on all
these parameters and so the hypothesis
that's quite well accepted it that
changes in the orbital parameters of the
Earth's Sun system are responsible for
that for that shift in the in the indeed
border of the desert with a hard desert
this is a picture that he assured the
distribution of vegetation in Africa and
on top of that you have these are the
lines of constant precipitation these
are the precipitation distribution
defining the desert borders somewhere
here and so with one of the models that
was developed in my group a model that
has representation of atmospheric
processes but also of vegetation
dynamics we were able to reproduce the
decline of precipitation from the south
to the north which also corresponds to a
decline in net primary productivity so
we think of precipitation as the measure
of the climate so it declines from the
dis border to north towards the desert
and a decline in that primary
productivity that goes with that so we
run the model we simulate this
equilibrium and then in a series of
experiments we modify the grass
conditions at the desert border so here
imagine we have a model of the climate
system it has the presentation for the
atmosphere it had representation for the
biosphere for the vegetation is coupled
through land surface fluxes of water and
and heat and that model when you run it
it reproduces the equilibrium and so one
of my PhD students Ghulam
did experiments in which she perturbed
the border of the at the border of the
desert the density of vegetation you see
here the model had an equilibrium of
precipitation of about two hundred and
fifty millimeters when you perturb the
grass the precipitation increases but it
goes back to an equilibrium if you
perturb it producing the density it
recovers again but if you perturb it
large enough it moves to a different
equilibria and that's from the
theoretical point of view that was a
very significant discovery because this
short for the first time that you have
multiple climate equilibrium the couple
land atmosphere system so people have
shown that you have this kind of
behavior multiple equilibria in coupled
ocean atmosphere systems this is the
only physically-based system model that
reproduce this kind of of multiple
equilibria meaning that the climate as
it exists has more than one equilibrium
under the same forcing depending on
initial conditions the idea that whether
systems are sensitive to initial
condition is well-established that the
chaos theory discovered by Lorenz at MIT
in the nineteen sixties the idea that
climate could have multiple equilibria
is a new concept that has been shown
only in couple ocean atmosphere systems
however this is the first time we showed
that for land atmosphere system
specifically for the region that's
basically close to the Sahara Desert so
as another student in my group then try
to use the same model which had
representation of the climate and the
vegetation to try and simulate what
happens to this distribution of
precipitation and their different
conditions of the orbital parameters so
we have zero K that means the orbital
parameters corresponding to today's
climate six K basically the orbital
parameters corresponding to the climate
6000 years ago and you see here we did
experiments assuming that vegetation is
static meaning that when the climate
changes the vegetation does not change
and feed back into the system and we did
a set of experiments where we assume
that the climate is
and you see here you know the desert
border is defined by the 200 millimetre
rainfall and when we do all these
experiments assuming initial conditions
as current vegetation we do not
reproduce significant expansion of the
desert it's only about 200 kilometers
what has been observed in paleoclimatic
records is expansion of the desert by
about 500 kilometers five degrees or
five hundred kilometres and thus you
don't get that when you initialize the
model to the current vegetation the only
time in which we were able to do that is
when we initialize the model with
vegetation that looked like the
vegetation that existed six thousand
years ago which is again bringing back
the idea that in order to be able to
simulate the climate of this region you
have to recognize the important role of
vegetation dynamics and their role in
defining more than one equilibrium for
the climate system in that area and so
this is a paper that was able here in
this case you could see here the border
of the of the of the Sahara retreated
from about 21 degrees north to about 15
degrees north which is about six degrees
north which is about six hundred
kilometers okay so this is in addition
to the theoretical value of this result
it provides a case for us on how what
kind of processes do you need to include
in simulating the climate of that region
not only for now but also looking at
future climates so the southward shift
of the desert margin helped in
triggering the emergence of the
pharaonic civilization along the nile
migration was a dominant mode of
adaptation to climate change and this is
something I didn't mention I didn't
emphasize enough but here you know in
this picture you see how when the
climate change people basically migrated
to the Nile to the Nile Valley you know
hmm not not yes so that's actually
exactly what you would expect and thus
when people look at climate change now
you know there is the potential and the
projection that they're going to be
significant migrations associated with
with with climate change in the future
actually we just finished submitting a
proposal to the MacArthur the MacArthur
Foundation at a group from MIT
suggesting that we would develop models
to project the climate of Bangladesh in
the future and we would would actually
our aim is to be able to project
conditions under which they will have
significant migration as a result of
climate change
and we are working with an NGO in
Bangladesh who would like to be able to
proactively plan for migration so that
if you could project like in 15 years or
20 years the conditions in a region of
Bangladesh would be so severe that
people has to migrate then if you have
that projection you could plan it and it
can be an orderly migration so the issue
of migration and how it relates to
climate change is an issue that's not
only like we see it in the past but but
it could also be a future issue this is
one of my favorite pictures this is a
drawing by David Roberts in 1850
travelling in Egypt and this is the road
and I lammeter you know the nida meter I
don't know if everyone here is familiar
with what an ILO meter is you know it's
like thermometer you measure temperature
and Volta meter you major vote and
myeloma tell you major denial and so and
so the milometer is basically this is
the river here and they have this
structure next to the river and you have
this graded bar so people come down
these stairs and they basically make
these measurements and that had been
going on in the Nile for for quite some
time and so based on that record we have
what I believe to be the longest human
record of geophysical phenomenon and I
think some of Joe here and and others
have maybe looked at this record and
analyze it I used it in the paper in
1999 that that he mentioned a lot of the
interestingly on the Nile level have to
do
is like you know I guess tax collection
is as that some of because the amount of
Taxation that they supplied had to do is
how much water is available and how much
agricultural productivity is there so so
that's in the in the intermediate period
between the thousands of years hundreds
of years time scale we have the longest
record for denial flow and I use this
recording in some of my research now
getting closer let me give you like a
very introductory note about about the
hydrology of the Nile so basically the
annual flow of the Nile is about 84
cubic kilometers and for many people if
you say that it doesn't mean anything
because if it for it to mean anything
you need to get calibrated right with
some with some system that you are
familiar with so at MIT I tell people
the Charlie's River flow is about the
cubic kilometer per year you know it's
all especially if you look at the
Charles River you know it's a small
River in front of Harvard you see it
flowing here coming to give this lecture
I figured out the connected Connecticut
River flowing from Massachusetts to
Connecticut is about 15 cubic kilometer
I think a place called Thomson bill
that's where it crosses from
Massachusetts to kinetic is about 15
cubic kilometer the Mississippi is about
500 the Yellow River is about 80 80
cubic kilometer so the Nile is 84 cubic
kilometer and usually I think about it
in terms of units of 12 cubic kilometers
okay so two of those units come from
Uganda into South Sudan one of the units
basically get lost through evaporation
and another unit comes from Ethiopia
here one cubic kilometer so that has to
the one that's remaining from Uganda to
give the White Nile two cubic kilometers
so White Nile gets two cubic kilometers
flowing and meeting the Blue Nile and
Khartoum in Sudan the Blue Nile brings
four cubic kilometers actually I'm sorry
four units so this is all in terms of a
unit is 212 cubic kilometers or two
units one unit then you have two units
you have four units coming from the
balloon
that makes it six coming in denial up
Bora River brings in one so that's seven
so the Nile in Egypt brings seven of
these units but if you want to see where
the water is coming from you see here
one four and one these are six units out
of the seven are coming from Ethiopia
okay that's important because it has a
lot of implications like you know for
example there is a whole effort now
something called the Nile Basin
initiative where they bring all these 12
countries Rwanda and Uganda and Kenya
and like so everyone that has anything
to do with the Nile and they sit in the
same table trying to figure out how to
share the water and I tell them you
can't do that because not all these
players have the same weight you know
some of them like for example Tanzania
and Ethiopia
there is nothing between the two and
there is nothing the climate of them
denia is different than if you Pia the
rainfall system that brings the red to
Tanzania and Ethiopia is different there
is no water flowing from Tanzania to
Ethiopia there is no connection but they
sit down on the Nile Basin initiative
and they argue and argue and argue and
if they really have something that they
share so understanding the hydrology of
the Nile is very important and so you
get from this picture that the rainfall
over a few PA is very important it's
actually six out of seven units that's
come that come from there and that's and
that's important in determining the
hydrology so this flux the the
fluctuations in the Nile River have been
of interest to people living in denial
for like a long time this is a story in
the Bible and the Quran do you know
Prophet Joseph and his you know dream of
seven years of plenty followed by seven
years of drought followed by seven years
of plenty followed by seven years of
droughts and shortages and and you know
people recite that in the Quran and I
think is storied in the Bible and and
and and other and other books there is
speculation and I don't know I I don't
think we know but there is speculation
that the furrow at the time of of Joseph
was a manhood of the third and I'm a
notably shared is the father of
Akhenaten but there are people who
dispute that and so it's not they may
not be any factual basis
behind that but this guy had
unprecedented prosperity and cultural
international power so that time had
been a time of really significant status
for for that part of the wallet so what
code is the year-to-year fluctuation of
denial we see it here in this figure
like you know there is a lot of
fluctuations and here we see it in the
story of joy F is really even if you
don't believe in any religion the fact
that these stories come in the Bible and
the Quran they point to the fact that
these fluctuations are important for
society are pretty important for for
people there and so one of these things
that we looked at recently with the
records and the mile had very good
records for example measured flow at s1
we have 150 years of data that's a
significant amount of data 150 years and
the fixtures of the of the of the
variation in the river you have a very
strong you know seasonality basically
you have very strong seasonality peaking
around September or so and then you have
very high level of fluctuations from
year to year this is 100 years of data
and you see how how rich is that signal
so you see it here you know more zooming
in you see very significant fluctuation
these are the kind of fluctuation that
George Evan and the story of Joseph
really is concerned about we have done a
paper in 1996 in which we shown that
there is a significant correlation
between the Nino phenomenon which is
something I'm going to talk about and
the annual flood of the Nile such that
warming which coincides with an in you
results in droughts so when you have a
linear you get droughts when you have La
Nina you get you get floods and the
correlation explains the the sea surface
temperatures in the Pacific Ocean
explains about 25 to 30 percent of the
inter-annual variability in the in the
flow of the Nile so let me give you for
those of you who are not familiar with
the menu let me give a little bit of
video that should give background
two years the El Nino phenomenon Kix
intellect in the Pacific Ocean around
the equator it can affect weather around
the world changing the odds of floods
droughts heat waves and cold seasons for
different regions even raising global
temperatures but what is El Nino and how
does it happen
firstly we need to know what's normally
happening in the tropical Pacific this
last stretch of ocean sees consistent
winds called trade winds that blow from
east to west
these winds push warm water near the
surface in their direction of travel so
the warm water piles up on western side
the ocean around Asia and Australasia on
the other side of the ocean around South
and Central America as the warmer water
gets pushed away from the coast it's
replaced by cold water which is pulled
up from deep and down in the ocean a
process called up wet this creates a
temperature difference across the
tropical Pacific with all the water
piled up in the West and in the east
water has extra heat to the air which
causes the air to rise with more vigor
and is this rising air that creates an
area
that rising air in the West sets up
atmospheric circulation across this part
world with warm moist air rising on one
side of the ocean and cooler drier air
descending on the other this circulation
reinforces the easterly winds so this
past world sits in a self-perpetuating
state until El Nino begins if conditions
are right tropical Pacific weather
systems or slow changes in the ocean
around the equator can set off a chain
of events which weekend or even reverse
the usual trade winds with weaken trade
winds there's less push of warm surface
water to the western side of the ocean
and less upwelling of cold water on the
eastern side this allows the usually
Condor parts in the ocean to warm
cancelling out the normal temperature
difference because the area of warmest
water moves so does the Associated wet
and unsettled weather
this changes rainfall patterns over the
equatorial Pacific as well as the
large-scale wind patterns it's this
change in winds which has a look on
effect changing temperature and rainfall
in locations around the world the baleen
paths are around the tropics where you
see an increase in the risk of floods in
Peru and droughts in Indonesia India and
parts of Brazil but virtually wherever
you are in the world El Nino has the
potential to affect you directly by the
weather or indirectly by associate
economic impacts there's another impact
from El Nino which happens because of
all the extra heat
this energy into the so you see he
didn't mention denial actually denial is
one of the most impacted region by
Armenia if you look at correlations as I
said earlier the sea surface temperature
in the pacific explains 25 to 30 percent
of the inter-annual variability in
mineral so on linear the major factor in
shaping climate variability and climate
change over the nile basin in the past
and in the future and actually another
application of an anu comes from the
fact that is quite predictable so this
is actually predictions made you know by
the ECMWF system they are made in april
and you can see that the ensemble of
predictions the observations very much
followed the mean of the ensemble so the
phenomenon is pretty predictable and so
if you could predict an in you and if
you know that El Nino occurrence is
results in droughts then you could
predict conditions of droughts or floods
on the Nile and you could do that with
significant lead time and that's what
methodology we have we have done is a
very simple methodology so we basically
say based on the answer index answer is
on linear Southern Oscillation is an
index of this phenomenon when it's warm
then you have basically a new new
condition when it's cold you have the
reverse which is nonlinear and you could
have normal conditions and then you
could compute the probability that the
flood of the Nile would fall in any of
these categories based on the past
record so we did that and we have this
table that could be used and actually is
being used operationally to make
seasonal forecasts of conditions of
flooding and droughts in the Nile
so basically if in one year you know
that the likelihood is that you are
going to have warm SST and Nino you
could almost rule out the possibility of
having a high flood so it's mostly
low or average flow vice-versa if you
have learn in your condition
you could almost rule out having low
flow and you could predict average to
high conditions in more recent history
if you look at this is the record and
the years here was full circle are years
in which you have an in you I would like
to bring your attention to these four
years these are four years towards the
end of the 19th century on early
twentieth century and you see every time
we had a very low flow year we had on
any new condition so actually this is
very I think find is very remarkable
especially I would like to bring to your
attention this 1888 event and 1888 is
significant because in Sudan you know is
related to what's called the famine of
the thirteen or six Hijri year in Sudan
the the the calendar is actually
according to the Hillary Hillary is like
the year in which the Prophet Mohammed
migrated from Mecca to Medina so that's
the Islamic calendar is based on that
and so when I grew up in Sudan I used to
hear from like my relatives and you know
grandmother and so on is like the famine
of of six of the year 6 which is the
firm enough likes 1806 when I started
looking at the records of the Nile the
first time you know the year six doesn't
have it didn't have any anaemia in it
but when you do the translation the year
six in history is corresponds to 1888
and that's that wasn't any New Year you
see it here is well featured and that
the year in which to Dan had a major
famine and so so this year had this
famine had a large impact with many
stories reflected in the in the oral
history however if you look at this same
record and I was discussing earlier with
with Joe the 1914 year is actually the
lowest flow year in the Nile that had
been recorded the flow was only about 40
cubic kilometer he did receive really
enough attention in term of studies this
is the year in which the Nile brought
the least water and that year although
the Nile brought
the least water there is no record of
any problem no famine no nothing I
haven't heard about that year in the
oral history okay so the question is why
and so in the 1880s it wasn't only that
you had a natural hazard from a drought
but often the socio-economic situation
was quite poor and unstable that's a
year in which to Dan was ruled by by guy
corner holliford to lie who was actually
busy at that time trying to you know
conquering soupier and he took all
people from their work and so the
socio-economic and political situation
was quite unstable so the lesson you
learn from there is that the risk from
climate variability or climate change is
not really just the natural hazard but
also the level of vulnerability in
society and so that's why adaptation and
being ready for for climate change is an
important is an important concept so
looking at the current estate in the
Nile Basin this is a table that I
generated based on the CIA World
Factbook and you see here the population
of Egypt is about hundred millions
Ethiopia 105 Sudan about 35 and the
population is growing across the board
you know you see the the economic
situation if you Egypt to the most
better shape than Sudan and Ethiopia
you know $13,000 per capita economies
are growing but you see quite
significant disparity in the production
of electricity per capita which is a
very good measure of how people like
standard of living you know Egypt has
like maybe four or five times what what
the average to peon gets you know the
average Sudanese and even the average
European is like eighteen times and so
the in general and and you see the level
of electrification in Egypt compared to
European Sudan is also very significant
disparity and at what points that's just
one element that points to urgent needs
for sustainable development in Africa
you know there is you know when you look
at Africa it's not the issues are not
only climate change the environment
there is the poverty and the
needs for development this is what I
call the equation of Africa's future
this is an equation that I invented a
couple of years ago and I'm actually I'm
very proud of it's a very simple
equation that tells you a lot about
what's going on in Africa I think and
and I think everyone here could
understand what they're this is you know
C is for crops so this is crops
production which means in agriculture
country this is really the economy you
know the economy Africa mostly
agriculture so the more crops you
produce the better in agriculture terms
W is the amount of water that's
available so that's basically water
availability which is mainly linked to
climate T is how you transform that
water into crops which is technology
what kind of technology you do so that's
why I'm using the word T and then I do
that per person which is P you know
population size so how much water how do
you use the water and how many people do
you have and that gives you some idea
about about your you know economic
status so if you do like 1801 at MIT I
think math here I don't know we have
numbers for the subjects over there
every subject has a number the basic the
basic calculus you do the you know
manipulate this equation and you end up
in this in this equation here and what
it is is actually economic growth that's
the relative change in the productivity
here change in water availability does
climate change technology adoption is an
important factor and population growth
is another important factor and the
interesting thing here is that
population growth is the only thing that
showed up with negative sign I like that
fact very much everything is positive
except when it comes to population is a
negative contribution so what what I
what I tell people this is my like list
of topics when I talk about things in
Africa I think these are the issues to
be we think about is climate change
technology adoption and population
growth and so let's look at them one by
one technology adoption in this contact
was context what technology
option is really agricultural technology
and so here is the agricultural
efficiency defined at the mass of crop
produced per unit volume of water okay
and thus function of how you use water
so how much volume of waters transpired
by plants per unit volume of water use
and crop productivity is how much crop
you produce per unit volume of water
those are two different things
this is hydrology and this is
agriculture productivity okay and so
when you look at that there is a need to
be efficient in terms of water use
efficiency there is a need to basically
line canals who use water more wisely
line canals you need to application
losses reduce them that's mean flood
irrigation versus drip irrigation so
that will all increase the water use
efficiency and you need to use
irrigation and irrigation is something
that had expanded during the 20th
century dramatically around the world
the the area equipped for irrigation
increased by a factor of five during the
20th century while in Africa is only six
percent of the cultivated land now is is
really related so Africa led the world
in term of of irrigation and you know
compared to 37% in Asia and 14% in Latin
America you look you zoom and you look
at Africa aside from the Egyptian Delta
and Jazeera in Sudan there is no
significant irrigation than in Africa
actually is very striking and explaining
what's happening in agriculture in
Africa is that you know there is very
little irrigation being done so there is
a strong need for more efficient
irrigation in the Nile
so going back to this equation now we
have water use efficiency we want to
have crop productivity and this is one
of the most striking figures that I I
really think is important to show what's
going on in the Nile and in Africa this
is how much productivity of Agriculture
has the function of application of
fertilizers and with application of
fertilizers it goes also irrigation and
other
technological advances these least
developed countries Tilman the person
who produced this figure told me these
are basically African countries African
countries use very little fertilizers
and produce very little in terms of
agriculture and so developed countries
of the world in Europe and North America
they are in red here Asian countries
have really went up the stairs here and
they are producing more so the issue of
low productivity of Agriculture in
Africa is a very important issue that
needs to be addressed you see that here
in the distribution of nitrogen
fertilizers around the world Africa very
little application compared to South
America North America Europe and Asia
here you see Africa is all in purple
there is very little in Egypt nothing
else including in the Nile Basin but you
look at Europe is being fertilized like
you know it's very significantly you
know Asia India had had his Green
Revolution China had his Green
Revolution you know North America is
large areas receive a lot of nutrients
however Africa is still down there so I
think in terms of adoption of technology
agriculture technology Africa has a long
way to go and that's any investments in
really in the Nile Basin or in Africa
that has to be a priority so technology
adoption is an area that needs a lot of
attention population growth is another
big problem in Africa I actually believe
that without addressing the population
growth in the Nile Basin and in Africa
there is no future for that continent
it's a very you know there may be broad
statement but I really believe it is and
the reason is is what I'm going to show
in a minute this is here the population
of Egypt Ethiopia and Sudan you know and
it's being increasing very rapidly I
came to you know to MIT as joe said is
1988 now in 30 years the population
doubled when I you know when I was at
school we were told the population of
Egypt is 40 millions now is 105 Millions
if you PM is similarly and you see it
here even with just what the population
momentum some of you are familiar with
that concept the population momentum is
huge and the population is going to
double in the next thirty years again
okay and that's that's a problem you
know what these numbers mean for water
per capita it brings these countries
from water scarce to absolutely water
scarce less than 500 cubic meters per
per person so the issue of population is
a very significant issue in the Nile
Basin look at look at here you know this
is the projections of how the most
populous ten countries in the world lit
in 1950 there was no country from Africa
1950 none of the African countries made
it 2015 Nigeria joined the list and the
projection by 2050 you'll have five
countries from Africa I think you have
five countries from Africa or four maybe
Nigeria Nigeria Congo Ethiopia need four
countries from Africa two of them from
the Nile Basin so two countries from the
Nile Basin are going to join the most
populous countries in the wallet okay
and the river flow is still the 84 cubic
kilometer you know it didn't change so
except for climate change is going to
add a little bit but not much
so that's that's a problem I think and
as I showed earlier here you know the
different projections they they make
very little difference on how much
increase so the story is the following
the world it now has seven billions
Africa has one of the seven the
projection by 2050 the world is going to
add two pinions one of those two is
going to be in Africa so the continent
that has the least capacity to absorb
any population is going to be and now
has 15% of the population is going to be
responsible for 50% of the increase okay
so the US that's a very grim picture for
Africa I think it needs it needs to be
to be addressed I go back to of not on
in this picture and actually you could
see one dominant thing
this picture has a lot of things I could
tell you about for example a snappin you
know seems to be very very nice to this
child African African men are not
supposed to be very like emotional to
their children that's not that's not
sort of as very positive in the African
culture in general nothing here you know
he's kissing his child but one other
thing you see here is that there are
three children's here in this picture
you know and when I did the search about
Ana Nefertiti she had six children okay
so by that time you know like thousands
of years ago you know a woman on average
will have that kind of number of people
the the best way to address the issue of
population is to increase the enrollment
of girls in secondary schools okay that
seems to be the most effective way it's
really a matter of conservation of time
nowadays in many parts of Africa girls
do not really go into secondary school
they stay at home get married and have
children
the more you have them spend time at
schools they would have the less time to
have to have more children so that's
that works this is the correlation that
you would expect you know African
countries are in green here and look at
the total fertility rate is about five
or six so we didn't move from the time
of of not until now okay it's still it's
still the same rate of of births and
that's something that I think has to has
to change and you see the rest of the
world lid you know basically moved down
here to two or so and that's that's not
what African is to go so these are the
second issue which is you know
technology adoption population growth
let's look at climate change and very
quickly and till recently the answers to
climate change
especially on denial we say that we
don't really know half of the models are
saying you're going to have more water
half of the models say that you are
going to have less water and this is
detailed in this figure recently I had a
PhD student of mine who made a little
bit of progress in this paper that that
yo mentioned earlier so this is records
of flow here in the Upper River and also
in the upper Blue Nile when these rivers
are analyzed
you know the
the moving average you find that there
is on average in the abre and in the
Blue Nile
they have been an increase in the mean
flow the mean increased by about 10
percent in the Blue Nile and 17 percent
in the upper river also the standard
deviation seems to be increasing
similarly and that that variability you
know in the past had been associated the
coefficient of variation in the Nile
flow this is this is a very interesting
figure this is the number of an inny on
La Nina events number of a lineal
landing events in the past record and in
blue you have the coefficient of
variation in the Nile and you see they
basically match each other so increase
occurrence of an inland Linea leads to
having more variability on the Nile
meaning more floods and droughts and so
they have been a couple of papers in
Nature climate change by a group of
oceanographers long group of
oceanographers that basically suggested
that they would be increasing frequency
of extreme and Anu events due to
greenhouse warming and increase
frequency of extreme landing events and
the global warming so basically they are
telling us this oceanographer is based
on all set of models that they run that
they are going to have more of these and
minion landing events so what that would
tell you would tell you that the Nile is
likely to have more variability okay and
so when this student of mine analyzed
the record of all the GCMs he showed
that you know they were going to be a
small increase in the mean by about 15%
however that will come up with an
increase in the standard deviation by
50% so think about it so what this is
saying that the future of the Nile is
going to be on average more water but
that water is going to come with a lot
of variability meaning one year you have
a lot of flow and some year next year
you have very low flow so what is the
solution of that we don't have engineers
here do we do you have anyone from you
don't have an engineering school at Yale
do you no we don't have we don't have
any there is no engineering school here
right there is okay so with this the
engineers in the room if you have a
river that
you know one here you have a lot of flow
the other year you have a small flow
what do you do hmm capture the water
store it build dams that's you know and
that's the fight in denial now is about
a dam that actually coming even it had
nothing to do with climate change that's
the soupier words to really just use the
record of that they have but what this
is saying there is more water a little
bit but if you want to really use it you
have to capture it and you have to store
it means you have to build more dams
okay so that's you know what's shown
here the number of an Indian land in the
events is going to increase in the
future consistent with this
oceanographer the studies and and so the
coefficient of variation of the Nile is
going to increase which means we are
going to need to build more dams we made
the estimates here in this figure about
you know this is the time and how the
storage in denial increased the highest
one dam was introduced in 1970 it
increased the storage by about 130 cubic
kilometers and now the girth which is
being planned is is basically going to
increase the storage however what we are
showing from this is that in the future
because of the increased variability
there has to be an increase in the
amount of storage that you are going to
need to have and so that's that's what
what this study basically basically
concluded and so I would like to show
this maybe it's getting a little bit the
time for the sake of time maybe I will
not show this video this is a video that
we have so do you have time okay so
let's let's show this video and it will
summarize the study
for millennia people have relied on the
fertile soils and constant flow of fresh
water in the Nile River Basin today this
river fills water bottles irrigate crops
and creates hydroelectricity climate
change however threatens to disrupt the
delicate balance between the mud and the
people it sustains a recent prediction
of climate models is an increased
occurrence of the climate oscillation
responsible for Amino and lemming year
now scientists at MIT are suggesting
this variability is also likely to be
reflected in the flow of the Nile River
resulting in more frequent floods and
droughts especially in the eastern Nile
region with tributaries running through
almost a dozen countries the Nile River
serves as the main water artery for
eastern Africa and for the 400 million
people living along its shores a vital
resource
unfortunately the Nama Basin is already
an ecosystem under significant stress so
what will happen as climate change
progresses according to the recent study
it's not looking good considering
climate model simulations of rainfall
and streamflow the research team
projected future River flow patterns
observational data were used to document
recent trends
future run of these models use
mathematical formulas that take into
account greenhouse gas emissions and how
they affect climate allowing scientists
to make future projections under the
business-as-usual scenario of emission
levels from these data a troubling trend
emerge the coming years and decades are
likely to see an increase in the
variability of river water levels
attributed to increases in future
occurrences of El Nino and La Nina
events for people living in the Nile
Basin
and relying on the resources it provides
this translates into more frequent
fluctuations manifested in extreme
floods and droughts the effects of which
are already being felt in 2015
regions along the Nile saw the worst
drought in a half-century causing crops
to fail and food prices to skyrocket and
leaving millions hungry a year later
hundreds of thousands of people were
displaced and houses destroyed by floods
along the river's banks scenes such as
these are likely to continue as climate
change progresses threatening
environmental sustainability local
cultures and food security in this
already fragile region with the
population in the Nile River Basin
expected to double by the year 2050 the
demand for water is growing stronger
every day while the data suggest ongoing
climate change will likely increase
overall average learn flow in the river
this additional water comes at a price
increased inter annual variability will
require building dams to store water
surplus during flood years for use in
drought years incurring the economic and
environmental costs this combination of
projected population growth and climate
so summarizing just the future of denial
vision I think control of the rapid rate
of population growth is the number one
priority not only for denial for Africa
really I think it's a very serious
problem that does not get enough
attention and I talked about it in most
of my presentations like this I talked
about it in Africa and people like you
know you know it's not it's
controversial but I think I think the
evidence is very clear that you cannot
go in the current in the current path
investments in irrigation and
agriculture technology fertilizers
better seeds is a close second it's very
important you know there are parts of
half you know when I first came to MIT
in 1988 in the Parsons Lab fertilizer
was a bad word because you know the
environmental chemists in the lab they
basically think of it as a source of
pollution because there is so much
pollution a fertilizer deployed in the
Midwest and elsewhere that it comes in
the drains and comes a problem you know
in the in Africa in many parts of Africa
actually the nutrients in the soil are
being depleted by not adding fertilizer
growing crops and then taking the crops
and supporting them you are taking
nutrients out of the soil
it's a very different world and so
investments in like fertilizer factories
for example I recently proposed that
Sudan with this change that's happening
a political change one of the things
that they should invest in is they
should build a big fertilizer factory in
the heart of the agricultural region and
produce a lot of nutrients that could
really go around and and supply the
soils so that's a very important factor
challenges of population growth adoption
of Agriculture technology and climate
change are much more significant than
those so he did any damn you notice that
I I hardly mentioned the
right I think the Gerdes is a
manufactured manufactured problem for
political reasons it's not really it's
not it's not even close to being the
heart of what the problem in denial
laziness is a symptom of the conflict
and it's not the root cause of it even
if tomorrow I was telling Joe earlier if
tomorrow Egypt and Ethiopia are happy
friends and they solve the problem of
the of the Girt we still have the
population growth right and we don't
have enough water
we still have climate change and we
still have agricultural productivity
that's very low those are the issues and
if you think about it if you increase
the agriculture productivity and if you
use water more efficiently you could do
more with the existing water and and
then you could be have less less
conflict adaptation to climate change
will be needed in the future so a better
plan for it now and it's absolutely the
time to ignite the Africa's green
revolution you know and if someone is
wondering where would I get the money to
ignite that revolution I have a slide on
that that I don't have the time to talk
about but that's that's it thank you
very much and sorry for going right that
was wonderful thank you very much
there's time for some comments questions
I'm gonna ask you to use this very
old-fashioned looking microphone just so
we record comments and questions
yeah please thank you
there political aspects to the water
distributional in the Nile Basin between
Ethiopia Sudan in Egypt are they in
agreement or are they competing and
especially given that Egypt is the more
advanced more powerful and one of the
two most populated countries what is its
relationship to the other two countries
regarding the distribution of water so
that's that's an important question you
know as I showed earlier the nile brings
84 cubic kilometers per year that's
measured at s1 you have to first
recognize that there is a difference
between Ethiopia and Egypt Ethiopia is
closer to the example of Ireland I
talked about when I first talked you
know you need to drain if you Pierre de
Nile drains water out of Ethiopia so it
has plenty of rainfall Egypt has no
rainfall it's all the water of the Nile
so that that's a significant natural
difference the 84 cubic kilometer that I
talked about is measured at Aswan in
1959 Sudan and Egypt signed an agreement
on sharing of that 84 cubic kilometer
that's measured at this one they built
the highest one dam so that after they
built the highest one dam no water goes
to the Mediterranean so they could use
all the water and they agreed that the
84 they estimated 10 cubic kilometer
would be lost through evaporation that's
comparable to the flow of the
Connecticut River a lot of water goes
through evaporation so they took that
out they didn't count again is Egypt or
Sudan they put aside the 74 they divided
it fifty five point five for Egypt and
18.5 for Sudan okay so that's an
agreement that's binding between Sudan
and all Sudan
because Sudan had a split into two
countries all Sudan and Egypt 55.5 18.5
a lot of my friends in Sudan you know
like to complain about this and this is
unfair
how can you give Egypt fifty five point
five and you give Sudan only eighteen
point five the truth of the matter is is
that agreement did not get into effect
till today because when would the
agreement come in the agreement would
come in into effect become binding if
Sudan starts using 20 cubic kilometer
then easy to say no no no you can't do
that you only have eighteen point five
okay you have to let the one point five
flow down to die now uses like maybe is
controversial but maybe fourteen fifteen
thirteen so still there is water that
flows from Sudan into egypt for free
okay it just goes there because you know
Sudan is not using it if you Pia however
does not recognize the agreement between
Sudan and Egypt they were not part of it
not not consulted they are not accepting
it so for them they don't like even the
word 1959 I organized a workshop at MIT
I brought people from Ethiopia Sudan and
Egypt and you know every time we talk
about 959 you know the blood pressure
from my CP and friends will go up they
don't want that's not really they don't
like it they don't want to talk about it
it's not something that they they accept
so if that's why you know when this dam
now is euboea wants to build bigger dam
you know there is no agreement between a
CPA and Egypt that could really guide
what what to do how to do that so we
have some ideas I have actually a book
coming soon about how to share this
water in a rational way so if you are
interested in the topic I could be happy
to send you a copy of the book it's
electronic book that will come very soon
but but but when you think here one good
news about climate change is that it's
going to bring in a little bit more
water okay it's about you know five six
seven cubic kilometer
that's actually good news because it
could have been the other way around
imagine in this situation where there is
already a conflict if climate change is
going to bring less water that's going
to be a problem so population going up
and water going down you know that's
that becomes but now I think like many
parts of the world climate change in
general would bring more water with
exceptional regions actually something
that's not realized it's not it's not
recognized enough is not emphasized
enough maybe more accurate about climate
change climate change in general would
bring more precipitation around the
world except with exceptions like the
Mediterranean other regions they are
going to get less water but the majority
of the region of the world are going to
get more water so the Nile is going to
get a share of it which is going to be
about 10 15 percent okay this is really
fascinating and that early 20th century
case study is a nice example I guess
that's sort of luck because in the
British were there in the early 20th
century of course and the night the 1902
dam was in place so that in part
mitigated what could have been a serious
problem in 1913-14 and the current
conditions though you say we need more
storage that seems pretty clear where
would you put more storage in the Nile
Basin given that GERD is gonna be online
in another year or two presumably where
else what do you conceive of that maybe
that's your paper but yeah that there
are there are sites in Sudan that had
been identified for potential potential
dams there are places in a few Pia where
you could do the same so there are sites
around and and it's wiser and smarter to
do the damming upstream where
evaporation would be significantly less
and so I think for now you know this is
a new concept the idea that with climate
change you are going to get need to have
more storage is something that we just
published a couple of years and it did
not really penetrate into the
sameer but but that's but there are
there are enough sites where they could
think of of building those dams but
above girl yes all in Ethiopia yes which
might create some interesting political
yeah yeah I think I think people have to
I think people have to resolve this
issue of how they cooperate you know how
they like share this water in a rational
way okay dared actually has one feature
about it that's very interesting that I
have a paper about it that hadn't been
published yet
Gared actually by virtue of his location
is brought in the interest of Ethiopia
and Egypt together because any use of
water consumptive use of water upstream
in Ethiopia meaning irrigation in
Ethiopia which is a consumptive use
hydropower is not a consumptive use you
just store and release irrigation
however you consume the water it
disappears so any consumptive use of
water in Ethiopia will reduce the water
not only for downstream countries but
for generation of hydropower in Ethiopia
South think about it because GERD is
located right at the border between
Sudan and Ethiopia so it's the last
point from which you cannot produce
hydropower and then consume the water
that's actually the very interesting
concept is it's not and and is an and
it's not by design it happened by chance
you know it happened my guess my friends
in the CP if they had a way of like you
know if now they have a resort maybe
they would put it up with sleep okay -
but but but but by virtue of where it is
it brings in the interest of the tupaea
and Egypt together so so but but I think
I think that's you know there is going
to be locations where they could where
they could store that water but but
clearly it's going to be you know one
thing about this paper that we just we
refer to here is that it's not only I
don't know what's happened here but if
it's not it's not only modeling result
but this is observations you see here in
observation the standard deviation had
been going up the mean increased and
yeah the standard deviation of the flow
has been going up and this is the
observations so so so you know within
Korea and also anecdotally you could see
that in recent records that you know you
get one year a lot of flooding there are
another year with low flow this is
changing any question any from the
student side of things oh please
okay thanks thank you very much everyone
for another yeah anyone else yeah please
that's a good question actually that's
what they call rainfall harvesting they
are doing a lot of that in Sudan but not
on the ground they are doing it
basically they build dams to capture the
rain and then use the water the problem
with that is that a lot of the water
evaporates yeah so one of the regions
that have been studying other than the
Nile I have the major project in it in
in Morocco and Morocco is a country that
not only it receives little rain now the
projections are that they are going to
get significantly less rain 30% so you
think that compare that to the Nile case
you know that's why I'm saying the Nile
case of like 10-15 percent is good news
because because like you know Morocco is
going to get significantly less if the
trends continue so one of the proposals
actually I was working on this just
yesterday was one of my affiliates they
weren't working with me from from
Morocco is we proposed a solution where
where you basically dig a storage
facility under the ground and when it
rains you take the water and you store
it and you close you lit you close the
lid on it you basically
you don't let it evaporate because in
Sudan they are doing a lot of frame for
harvesting but but when you build the
dam and the water gets collected and
then it evaporates a lot of it
evaporates and so or or seeps into the
soil so you lose it and so we need to
have more and more of these kind of
engineering solutions to be able to
provide enough water for people around
the world okay yeah thank you thank you
for
[Applause]
[Music]